if we lose a sense of our american
history
we'll lose what it is that unites us
as one people
[Music]
in 2020 the claim that america is
infected with
systemic anti-black racism is a lie
this is not mlk's hopeful message of
racial reconciliation
it's a dark indictment of america and we
should reject it
by the end of august it's actually true
that today
we don't do a good job of teaching our
history
to our own students to our own children
king in his i have a dream speech was
trying to
explain what he meant when black
americans were calling for civil rights
they were not calling for
black rights they were calling for what
they were owed
as citizens america had slavery
and america had jim crow and while it is
undeniable that we have
betrayed and fallen short of our ideals
at times
this remains an extraordinary nation
with a great past
and history should do justice to that in
the way that it's taught to the future
generations dedicated to the
propositions
people in the united states took
seriously the effort to implement what
jefferson said in the declaration of
independence that all men are created
equal
the principle emphasizes the common
humanity under the skin
we're all as moral beings
civil rights properly understood lays
the ground for human flourishing
and america is distinguished because
it's central idea
the whole purpose of the government is
to secure
our rights as one nation with liberty
and justice for all our achievements are
grounded
in the principles of our nation's
founding this country was
a product of debate a product of
discussion a product of deliberation
and a deliberation that ultimately
produced the freest
country that the world has ever seen i'm
lucas morell
i'm paul moreno i'm david azerad and
kevin poyness
this is our course on civil rights
let's begin